our Series a more perfect union aims to
show what unites us as Americans as far
as stronger than what divides us this
morning we introduced you to Rebecca
LaSalle who gave the ultimate gift one
of her organs saved the life of a
one-year-old child unlike most of the
8,000 liver donors in the u.s. last year
LaSalle didn't know or she didn't care
either who received that gift she simply
did it because she says she wanted to
help somebody else Mary Peterson was
there when she met the little boy she
saved and in a moment you'll see only on
CBS this morning
there is joy watching an 18 month old
discover the world but for Manila
Gonzalez these moments might not have
happened shortly after his birth doctors
discovered that Manolo had a
life-threatening defect causing his
liver to fail he was lethargic and
wouldn't eat solid food the only cure
was a transplant and six months ago he
got one at Children's Hospital Colorado
Samantha Gonzalez is Manila's mom what
happened and how fast it had happened
after at the transplant the moment he
woke up really a complete 180 he was
ready to eat the same day he was ready
to start crawling what saved Manila was
a decision by 24 year-old Rebecca Lowe
sound a complete stranger living 700
miles away in Montana who decided to
donate part of her liver to anyone who
needed it I merely just wanted somebody
else to live without even knowing it
wasn't your brother or your cousin or
anyone it was just a someone just
someone because because nobody deserves
to suffer
Rebecca is what doctors call an
altruistic donor meaning she gave a part
of an organ without specifying who would
get it and this was her second time two
years ago she also donated a kidney but
the liver transplant is a far more
difficult and risky operation there's
very few people in the world who have
donated part of their liver and a kidney
dr. Elizabeth
for it removed part of Rebecca's liver
at the University of Colorado Hospital
she says living donor transplants make
up about 4% of all liver transplants
done in the United States each year of
that 4% the number of people who are
altruistic donors is extraordinarily
small but with altruism comes a healthy
dose of skepticism
she was also evaluated by a psychiatrist
and a social worker and a nurse
coordinator so she really almost had to
talk you into this in some ways yes what
convinced you it was her demeanor and
her passion and her conviction and her
maturity let's just see Rebecca
recently returned to the hospital for a
six-month checkup and for the first time
met Manolo the child she said
life-saving for Manila life-changing for
Samantha he saved my life
so the fact that like you saved his like
there's no words I can express to you
how how thankful I am for what you've
done if what she did is extraordinary
why she did it is even more impressive
and it all goes back to a lesson her
mother drilled into her everyday before
I could walk to school when I was a
little girl she would say make the world
and you had to say a better place and
you'd always grown it out but it was
something that actually she did instill
in me and I do want to make the world a
better place mom was right yes right not
only does that explain Rebekah's
inspiration I don't ever want you to
have to feel
indebted or feel like you have to say
thank you because he he deserved it it
also explains the emotional letter she
wrote for Manolo to read when he grows
up most of all I hope that this
opportunity will inspire you to help
others to make the world a better place
oh my love Rebecca so this is a story
that may never end because there are
many more good deeds yet to come for CBS
this morning
Barry Peterson Aurora Colorado well
we're very happy to report the little
Manolo is doing well as doctors say he
has to stay on anti-rejection
medications for the rest of his life but
aside from that they say that he will
grow up and live a normal healthy life
Rebecca is extraordinary and what a
lesson that her mother taught and you
know your mom tells you something you do
kind of grown it out but it's amazing
how that stuff sinks in and sticks with
you yeah would not be able to do that a
lot myself included I think it's
extraordinary that she that she listened
to what her mother said and now manola
will hopefully match a selfless way in
such a selfless way when talking about
that and some of the other stories that
we've done is the idea of selfless
sacrifice hmm that someone who engages
in that is really just an incredible
person yeah I'm so happy that Barry
brought that story because to be in the
presence of that kind of grace even if
you can't do it Gail just to be in the
presence of it you're gonna you know do
doesn't impact youth yeah well maybe I
could do something else that's right it
definitely affects you Barry Peterson we
thank you too yeah Barry thank you